the morning after dozens of Kamikaze
drones were launched at the Ukrainian
capital
life in Kiev may seem normal
but for residents such as the owner of
this vehicle caught in the path of
falling debris it is not
Professor I was driving cologne there
was an air raid siren I wanted to get
home as fast as possible I heard
explosions and after passing the traffic
light there was a flash right in front
of me and an explosion under the car I
have a headache right now and a noise in
my head I don't feel well because I
haven't slept
Valentin says he feels lucky to be alive
damage to commercial vehicles like this
from falling debris almost certainly
affects people's livelihoods drone
attacks being carried out in places like
this areas where there are residential
apartment blocks people's homes
ukrainians say is indicative of a
campaign of fear being carried out
against civilians
the attack in the early hours of Sunday
morning was heard across the city center
Ukraine says air defenses neutralized
the majority of the Shaheed drones but
the attack still left a mark in several
neighborhoods
one damaged apartment block immediately
behind the U.S embassy coincidence or
not a worrying sign
it was very frightening experience I
heard the sound like motorbike flying
over a wrestling sound then there was a
powerful explosion followed by a huge
flash of light my window curtain turned
off and the jars I had on my windowsills
were shuttered
there has been no let up to near nightly
attacks Countrywide by comparison this
latest strike was less intense than
previous ones but came just hours after
the release of a joint communique by G20
countries
Ukraine criticized the statement for
being soft on Russia the foreign
Ministry posting aversion with its own
Corrections of texted said failed to
single out or directly condemn Russia
for the ongoing attacks on Ukraine
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera